nouvel épisode de la série dans son
corps aujourd'hui je reçois un nouvel
invité qui vient nous parler de sa
particularité à lui on en a déjà parlé
dans une vidéo précédente
mais bon vous allez comprendre si vous
regardez jusqu'au bout on accueille
docteur norman dr bossman et
vulgarisateur scientifique sur youtube
et étudiant en biologie alors neumann
salut salut
quelle est la particularité à toi ben
particularité c'est que j'ai été
diagnostiquée gilles de la tourette
quand j'étais tout petit et donc j'ai eu
des tic et j'ai encore un peu d'éthique
un peu moins depuis que je parle je
pense trois autres comme ça fera quatre
ans le syndrome gilles de la tourette
n'est pas une maladie psychiatrique mais
neurologique qui toucherait les
neurotransmetteurs au niveau du cerveau
tu te souviens
le moment où tu t'es rendu compte que tu
avais un truc je veux
je pense que c'était quand j'étais à
l'école en école primaire
donc on cm1 ou cm2 mais j'ai été
diagnostiquée a priori est vachement
plus tôt mais je ne savais pas trop ce
que c'était c'est mes parents qu'ils ont
su avant moi évidemment parce qu'ils
doutaient qu'ils avaient quelque chose
mais je pense est et ouest et m1 au ce2
camp quand je voyais que j'avais des tic
des expressions des choses que les
autres enfants faisait pas à quoi c'est
une maladie génétique rare mais j'ai
déjà expliqué tout ça dans une vidéo
donc si ça vous intéresse pas aller la
voir
je vous mets le lien dans la description
et tu te souviens de ce que tu t'es dit
à ce moment-là de te rendre compte que
bah justement tu as tu faisais des
choses que les autres faisait pas ouais
je trouvais ça un peu pas injuste mais
je trouvais ça un petit peu chiant parce
que déjà c'était un petit peu sujet à
moquerie alors papa de ouf mais un petit
peu quand même mais surtout que moi ça
jouait vachement sur la concentration
du coup j'avais pas mal de problèmes à
l'école pour suivre
écoutez les professeurs etc donc j'avais
j'ai eu pendant pas mal d'années des
mauvais résultats
alors est-ce que c'est directement lié à
ça je sais pas mais en tout cas ça ça à
jouer forcément
donc ouais je me suis dit c'est chiant
j'espère que ça va vite passer des
médecins disaient que ça allait passer
avec l'adolescence
donc je me suis dit attends ouvert à
l'époque les manifestations dont tu
parles c'était c'était quoi concrètement
en fait ça a démarré avec
les premiers si lille c'est vraiment
bizarre mais c'était un peu pour un an +
cirque quand j'étais tout petit je
passais avant de m'endormir je tapais la
tête contre mon oreille mais vraiment
jusqu'à ce que je m'endorme quoi comme
ça très longtemps quoi jeunesse à très
bizarre
c'est marrant parce que j'ai rencontré
des gens qui faisaient un peu ce même
genre de truc mais différemment
retournent à leur tête comme ça moi
c'était vraiment je tapais la tête
contre marié c'est quand j'avais deux
trois ans quoi d'ailleurs ma mère a
enregistré avec un magnéto à l'époque
pour pour garder ça parce que c'est un
petit peu étonnant quand même et du coup
je me suis rien entendu il ya pas
longtemps et c'est un petit peu bizarre
après c'était avec les yeux notamment
gelé je les ai aller en arrière je
faisais souvent des gestes avec ma
bouche tout ce que je touchais je le
sentais de ce genre de choses là à des
bruits un petit peu aussi de gorge
voilà c'était ce genre de truc là alors
quand on pense tourette
on imagine des gens qui hurlent des gros
mots tout le temps mais en réalité ça ne
touche que 10 à 15% des personnes
atteintes n'avait pas l'espèce de
représentations caricaturales qui est de
créer des gros mots tout simples un truc
non j'avais passé ce truc là et j'ai
jamais eu j'ai jamais vu ça je pense que
ça c'est vraiment le cas extrême poussé
moi c'était pattes
c'était j'avais beaucoup de tic mais
c'était pas des trucs hyper contraignant
quoi j'ai quand même eu de la chance
dans son de ce côté là après le truc de
taper la tête contre le reste est quand
même un peu moins notamment quand tu
pars en classe de classe derrière avec
tes collègues
enfin aller à l'école d'ailleurs j'ai
réussi à arrêter ce tic à cause de ceux
de ce départ scolaire parce que je me
suis dit si je le fais le soir c'est pas
possible que les gens vont prendre pour
un taré du coup j'ai réussi à me
canaliser à l'arrêter grâce à ce stage
de classe de mer c'était bien mais non
j'ai jamais eu ce truc de dire des gros
mots d
des choses frénétiquement heureusement
entendue
est ce que tu penses que tu disais que
c'était un chien est ce que tu as tu as
eu des petits des types des trucs qui
t'ont aidé à apprendre à vivre avec ce
truc là en attendant ça en attendant que
ça passe
non pas vraiment j'ai j'ai été consulté
des médecins des spécialistes des psys
pour essayer de voir d'où ça promet
alors ça m'a pas vraiment aidé de savoir
d'où ça venait
pourquoi j'avais ces choses là pas du
tout même ça m'a plu ce même je pense
choqué qu'autre chose de faire tous ces
tests les trucs bizarres qu'on compte
qu'on te dit de faire mais sinon à part
attendre et en fait on a toujours répété
bon bah ça va finir par passer
donc je me suis dis bah essaye de quand
tu sens que tu as envie de le faire
l'éthique ou autres bas empêche toi de
les faire quoi donc en fait des fois
j'essaie juste de me canaliser
et de me calmer j'ai fait beaucoup de
skate ça m'aide vraiment à me dépenser à
fond pour pour me fatiguer en fait et de
ce fait je pensais plus trop à aller
faire quoi donc
mise à part attendre et me dépenser à
fond dans certaines activités
je n'ai pas d'autres types ce perso quoi
et tu disais que tu avais pas eu trop de
moqueries à l'école
le regard des autres à cette période là
tu t'en souvenir douloureux ou
il ya eu il ya eu des fois où j'avais
des moqueries mais c'était je pense que
j'ai des souvenirs de 2,2 d'enfants qui
se moquaient de moi tu vois
mais c'était s'était jamais très
longtemps puis et puis c'était pas enfin
je sais pas c'était des moqueries comme
on se moque quand on a quant à 8 ans de
quelqu'un passait s'est jamais vraiment
jamais vraiment vexant au point que ça
te marque à fond donc non je le sava de
ce côté là j'ai vraiment eu de la chance
et puis j'avais toujours quand même des
plein plein plein de potes qui est
qu'ils s'en foutaient quoi totalement
qui les voyait même plus en fait c'est
ça j'ai eu de la chance là dessus que
j'ai pas été trop victimes de moqueries
donc ça va et donc du coup ça disparu
comment d'un coup progressivement n'a
pas disparu j'en ai encore pas mal mais
c'est juste que j'apprends vraiment à
les camoufler et je sais même pas en
fait je sais même pas si je les fais ou
pas mais je pense que je pense que ça va
mais ça ça c'est vraiment dissipé à
l'adolescence comme comme les psys et où
m'avez dit vers 18 19 ans ça a commencé
à se calmer sur plein de types
différents de ce qui est marrant c'est
qu'on en a d'autres qui sont apparus
aussi étonnamment et là tu te dis merde
[ __ ] c'est chiant ce truc quoi c'est
pas possible
apparemment ça devrait partir et actes
on a d'autres qui arrivent donc c'est
bizarre mais en fait j'apprends petit à
petit a à me canaliser j'essaie de
méditer pour me
vraiment me calmer sur ces choses là et
puis bah ça va ça je pense que j'en ai
vraiment de moins en moins donc c'est
vraiment avec l'adolescence le début de
la vie adulte que ça commence à partir
le fait de les deux un peu contraint de
canaliser tout le temps c'est pas un
truc qui aujourd'hui qui est fatiguant
bah non parce que je pense que j'ai
vraiment réussi à évoluer avec ça en
fait et
et en fait j'ai appelé j'aurais du mal à
trouver la fin à savoir si je me
canalise ou si vraiment ça tend à
disparaître clairement certains y
il ya dans certaines dans certains cas
de figure où je vraiment je le sens que
je me force à ne pas le faire alors ça
reste toujours assez sobre parce que je
suis pas non plus atteint de deux
tickets extrêmement forte
mais sinon je pense que ça s'attend plus
à disparaître plutôt que que je me
canalise en fait donc ça va c'est pas
très contraignant
maintenant en tout cas il ya quelques
années c'était encore un petit peu relou
mais là ça va vraiment c'est presque
nous mêmes qui nous le faisons c'est ça
en fait et donc effectivement des fois
on se
on se retient guillemets et après
parfaite à une crise ou pas tu t'en fais
un petit peu plus et là c'est un peu
chiant qu effectivement dessus enfin
c'est vraiment une maladie entre
guillemets ou tu es seul avec toi-même
quoi parce que c'est ça qui est terrible
avec ce syndrome c'est que hill et les
traitements fallait pas vraiment de
traitement doit assez
faut que faut que le temps passe et tu
verras ça risque de passer ou pas il ya
encore plein aujourd'hui à 40 ans qui
ont encore des tic marqué il a plein des
gens connus à la télé on voyait ils sont
bourrés de tic
bah ça passera pas et c'est comme ça
quoi mais après au bout d'un moment on
fait quand tu grandis que tu deviens
adultes on s'en fout en fait les gens à
qui tu traînes avec qui tu es au jour le
jour
pareil sans de foot aussi en fait donc
au final c'est pas très grave
en tout cas dans mon cas donc cas de
figure s'était pas non plus quand
j'étais petit c'était un peu c'était
assez poussées maintenant ça va mais ça
va je pourrais vivre avec ça va pas me
voilà aujourd'hui c'est pas un truc
c'est pas un truc auquel tu pense en
permanence c'est pas un truc qui enfin
que tu as toujours à l'esprit toile et
artesia défaut je pense pas du tout oui
il ya plein de fois où j'y pense pas du
tout d'ailleurs la plupart du temps je
pense pas du tout mais
il ya des fois où je me dis [ __ ] j'ai
27 ans ça passe
enfin il y en a toujours il ya des types
que j'avais quand j'étais au ce2
justement qui sont toujours là pascal
terrible ils vont sûrement me suive
toute ma vie et puis bah mais bon c'est
comme ça quoi ça va peut-être se passer
ça peut-être passer un moment ouvert je
sais pas trop est-ce que tu as souvenir
de d'un conseil que quelqu'un tu auras
donné pour justement pour t'aider à à
vivre avec a pas de faire une montagne
de ce truc là pas tellement en fait m'a
toujours dit mais c'est pas grave c'est
rien ça va passer voilà donc le truc
c'est que ça va passer c'est tout ce que
je j'ai vraiment pu retenir est alors du
point de vue des autres c'est pas grave
c'est sûr c'est pas grave mais a de son
point de vue personnel c'est un petit
peu plus chiant mais non en fait je
connaissais personne qui avait vraiment
des tic comme moi donc
donc ce n'était pas évident non plus de
discuter avec les gens de ce problème là
ce pour ça comme chez eux tout à l'heure
j'en parle très rarement quoi mais dans
ma copine
il ya plein de choses que je n'ai jamais
raconté quoi parce que j'ai un peu honte
suis pas je trouve pas ça très très
stylé quoi donc voilà j'avais pas dans
mon entourage des gens qui avaient cessé
même souci de ce fait des conseils
n'avait pas des masques même les
spécialistes les psys et touba à part
dire votre enfant il est spécial et les
différents il a sa forêt qu'ils
canalisent qu'ils se calment bail à rien
d'autre qu'à et toi t'aurais en un
conseil à donner des gens corel le
syndrome de la tourette ou
des tic bas ce qui est terrible c'est
que 13 h je crois pas en fait jusque
effectivement ça va certainement
s'atténuer avec le temps
donc il faut être patient réussir à se
calmer avec différentes activités ça ce
serait peut-être le quand même le type
ce numéro un c'est de trouver un une
activité dans laquelle on peut s'évader
tu vois que ce soit le dessin ça m'a
beaucoup aidée aussi
c'est vraiment l'activité dans laquelle
j'étais calme serein voilà je pensais à
rien je pense que ça c'est important
essayer de canaliser son esprit dans une
autre activité
j'ai encore eu des témoignages après la
vidéo que j'ai fait de gens sur twitter
ou autres qui le vivent vraiment mal et
son institut parce que ils ont vraiment
des lourds des lourds handicaps à cause
de ça et pareil quoi il faut être fort
et essayer de essayer d'être au dessus
de ça même si c'est pas facile vous
regardez la garder la pêche comme un
certain rapport le dit si bien
merci beaucoup d'autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]